AND THE MANAGER
OF BUGS "A" TO "Z,"
A PEST-CONTROL COMPANY
BASED OUT OF WOODLAND HILLS,
CALIFORNIA,
AND HE'S DESPERATE
TO EXPAND HIS BUSINESS
BEYOND THE RESIDENTIAL
HOMES HE NORMALLY SERVICES.
- IT'D BE GREAT IF, I MEAN,
WE LAND ANY KIND OF HOTEL WORK.
- JAVIER WANTED A CONTRACT
WITH A MAJOR HOTEL,
AND I HAD THE PERFECT METHOD
TO WIN HIM THAT DEAL.
RATHER THAN MAKING IT
LOOK LIKE THE HOTEL HAS
AN EXTERMINATOR VISITING,
WHY DON'T YOU INSTEAD
MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THE HOTEL
IS WINNING AN AWARD?
- RIGHT.
- EVERY HOTEL'S GREATEST FEAR IS
HAVING TO HIRE AN EXTERMINATOR,
BECAUSE THEIR ARRIVAL
IS BASICALLY AN ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT THE HOTEL HAS PESTS,
SO IF JAVIER COULD DISGUISE
HIS PURPOSE
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE HE'S THERE
TO GIVE THE HOTEL AN AWARD,
HE'D NOT ONLY DELIGHT GUESTS,
BUT SURELY WIN A CONTRACT
WITH THE HOTEL
THAT WANTS TO KEEP
THEIR PEST PROBLEM A SECRET.
- NOW, HOW--I MEAN,
DO I SHOW UP WITH--
I MEAN, I JUST--
I-I--AS FAR AS, I MEAN--
- IF CUSTOMERS SEE YOU
COMING IN,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE LIKE,
"OH, THIS HOTEL
IS REALLY GOOD,"
YOU KNOW, RATHER THAN SEEING
AN EXTERMINATOR
AND BEING LIKE,
"OH, THIS HOTEL IS NOT SO GOOD."
- [laughs]
YOU'VE DONE THIS BEFORE.
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE A BUSINESS MAJOR.
I MEAN, WHAT'S THE WORST
THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN?
- JAVIER WAS ON BOARD
WITH THE CONCEPT.
SO, TO SELL THIS TO A HOTEL,
I NEEDED TO SHOW THEM
EXACTLY HOW THE SYSTEM
WOULD WORK,
SO I HAD ONE OF JAVIER'S
SERVICE VANS REWRAPPED
TO LOOK LIKE A DELIVERY VEHICLE
FOR THE HOTEL EXCELLENCE AWARDS,
A VERY PRESTIGIOUS ORGANIZATION
THAT I MADE UP.
THEN JAVIER AND I WORKED
TO DEVELOP A DISCREET METHOD
FOR EXTERMINATING
EVERY ROOM IN A HOTEL.
LIKE, SOME SORT OF SECRET...
- A COMPARTMENT
OR OR AN OPENING.
- COMPARTMENT THAT OPENS UP.
WITH THE SYSTEM NOW IN PLACE,
I GOT PERMISSION
FROM THE HISTORIC MAYFAIR HOTEL
TO SHOOT A DEMONSTRATION VIDEO
OF OUR METHOD THAT WE COULD THEN
PRESENT TO THEIR MANAGEMENT.
IT BEGINS BY ARRIVING
IN OUR COVERT VEHICLE,
THEN REMOVING WHAT LOOKS
LIKE A LARGE TROPHY
THAT'S BEING AWARDED
TO THE HOTEL.
THIS SERVES A DUAL PURPOSE
OF BOTH GETTING
OUR EQUIPMENT INSIDE,
AND IMPRESSING GUESTS,
AS THEY SEE THAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY RESIDING IN THE HOTEL
WITH THE LEAST AMOUNT
OF BEDBUGS.
- WITH THE LEAST BEDBUGS?
- YEAH.
- SO IT'S A POSSIBILITY
OF SOME BEING THERE.
- WE'RE JUST DELIVERING
THE AWARD,
WE DON'T KNOW.
- OH, OKAY.
- THEN, WE MAKE OUR WAY
INTO THE PRIVATE BACK OFFICES
WHERE WE CAN SAFELY REMOVE
ALL OUR GEAR
WITHOUT ANYONE SEEING.
ONCE THAT'S DONE,
WE CONVERT OUR AWARDS TABLE
INTO A CUSTOM-DESIGNED
MAID CART,
AND I CHANGE MY OUTFIT
TO LOOK NATURAL PUSHING IT.
THE HOLLOWED-OUT INTERIOR
THEN ALLOWS JAVIER TO TRAVEL
FROM ROOM TO ROOM
WITHOUT DRAWING ANY SUSPICION
FROM HOTEL GUESTS.
[beeps]
YOU OKAY IN THERE?
- YEAH.
- WHEN WE GET
TO AN INFESTED ROOM,
THE CART BLOCKS THE DOORWAY
AND JAVIER IS ABLE
TO SNEAK OUT
WITHOUT ANYONE SEEING.
A QUICK HANDOFF OF THE VACUUM
THEN GETS OUR EQUIPMENT INSIDE,
AND JAVIER CAN GET TO WORK
SPRAYING DOWN
THE PEST-RIDDEN AREAS.
ALTHOUGH WE DIDN'T
FIND ANY IN THIS HOTEL,
JAVIER TOLD ME HE OFTEN
ENCOUNTERS MATTRESSES
THAT GET SO INFESTED
WITH BEDBUGS
THEY HAVE TO BE THROWN OUT.
SO I ALSO WANTED TO SHOW
THE HOTEL MANAGER
THAT WE HAD A METHOD
TO SECRETLY DISPOSE OF ONE
WITHOUT GUESTS THINKING
ANYTHING FISHY WAS GOING ON,
AND SINCE THE MAYFAIR CATERED
TO A LOT OF ASIAN CLIENTELE,
THE PERFECT COVER
WAS OBVIOUS.
IN THE GUISE
OF AN IMPROMPTU CELEBRATION,
WE WERE ABLE TO TAKE
A MATTRESS
STRAIGHT THROUGH THE LOBBY,
AND ONCE OUTSIDE,
ALL IT TOOK WAS A QUICK
IDENTITY CHANGEOVER
TO KEEP EVERYTHING
LOOKING NORMAL TO ONLOOKERS.
THEN, IN THE BLINK OF AN EYE,
WE'RE GONE,
WITHOUT ANYONE EVER KNOWING
THE HOTEL HAD A PROBLEM
WITH PESTS.
SO LATER THAT WEEK,
I WAS HOPEFUL OUR SALES VIDEO
WOULD BE ENOUGH TO WIN OVER
THE MAYFAIR MANAGER,
MIKE SCHOEFFIN.
- UNDERNEATH THAT DRAGON
IS OUR MATTRESS
THAT WAS COVERED WITH BEDBUGS,
INFESTED WITH BEDBUGS.
- AND YOU CAN SEE WE'VE BEEN
DEVELOPING A NEW METHOD
OF SPRAYING THE PUBLIC AREAS
USING A BLIND MAN'S CANE.
SO TO GUESTS,
IT JUST LOOKS LIKE,
"OH, THERE'S A BLIND MAN
STUMBLING AROUND THE LOBBY."
- RIGHT.
- SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE ABOUT.
- AND ONCE OUR SALES VIDEO
WAS DONE,